hey hey have you all met before no we've
never met but come on the eighth
appearance look at that we've we've
actually met before stop it wait wait we
dated in high school oh yeah that's
right that was my boo we went to prom
and everything he's not memorable
laughed at him all the time he was
talking about it unless somebody had a
great suit at prom let me tell you that
yeah
I bet you were the guy that she wanted
to show up looking like Dumb and Dumber
in those suits were you
is that we had
a tea that sold pajamas was from the
creep okay so I love that I will have
them yeah crazy sexy cool okay so wait I
hear that you're working at Eddie Murphy
now is that right
that's incredible yes I was my first
movie it is called Candy Cane Lane
um it is Eddie Murphy is at the helm
with Tracy Ellis Ross and Robin thidi
and like oh my God it's Cass wow it's
incredible
um we just did our first Zoom table read
over the holidays and I was shaking
because I'm such a huge Eddie Murphy fan
when I was 13 from like 13 to 16 I would
watch re-watch all of his snls and all
of his movies everything so like to be
able to even see my name with his is
just a huge dream come true absolutely
so what your character ghost is a ghost
from the 1920s yes she's a fun costume
1920s prohibition era Jazz Singer her
name is Alberta Haynes yes oh my gosh
[Applause]
so I didn't know you sang as well you do
everything listen I didn't know I was
saying either Kelly
like the actors are like sure I can
sexual skills I was like Alto that's
what it is right
um so they cast me I actually sang in my
audition just in the lines and they're
like oh she must be able to sing I was
like yo I'm just playing around so I've
actually had to start uh singing lessons
during the process I've done dance
lessons and I want to learn the
Charleston and all the dances from the
time period
um and I just think playing this role is
so iconic because as a black artist the
1920s were so incredible for us at that
time culturally and like I just want to
give her her just do and all those
artists that came before me so playing
this role is just a dream
I love like as an actor like y'all get
to learn all these like different skills
for your role that's cool then you end
up like learning all these these cool
things and nobody really gets a chance
to do or takes the time to do it's
amazing and um it's like the best role
I've ever played so far in my career and
it's cool also getting to work with
Ensemble roles McIver who I know has
been on the show in ukash and bukar
there are the bestly leads in the
business and we are just so honored to
be working with them weekly I love your
cats we've had them here and Rose
actually said that you all get very
competitive like it's a competitive cast
y'all we almost didn't have a season two
okay what what was the game okay it was
between Mancala but I'ma tell you the
real game was Scrabble Scrabble almost
took us out Richie Moriarty who plays
Pete
um and Asha grodman who plays Trevor the
guy with no pants
um they're very good at Scrabble and I
thought I was great but Richie had
spelled sommelier and got a triple word
score and then used all of his letters
and still to this day I think he cheated
I'm like how did you spell sommelier
with all these letters and we stopped
talking for months months
months Richie I know you cheated
that's an incredible word yeah it's
serious yeah it's no joke so we actually
decided as a cast you know we're not
gonna do Scrabble no more we're just
gonna let it go this is this is
literally me and my sister and my mother
will play Scrabble and I don't even know
why we play y'all my mother every time
almost flips the board she's like she's
like that is not a word it's always she
and my sister going at each other it's
the most enjoyable time with my family
for me are y'all competitive are you
yeah I'm dyslexic I can't spell
I look at Scrabble I'm like yeah these
seem to be all spelled correctly they
were all in front of you oh my God it's
amazing how games that shouldn't be
subjective can still cause such that's
me and Connect Four too yeah Connect
Four is if I can play Connect Four yeah
I'm good at that I'm ready
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]